good morning John so my Hospital
strangely enough has a secret special
entrance at the bottom of the parking
garage just for cancer patients the
first time I arrived at this door and I
read this little sign I was like oh
shoot we're gonna have to find some
other way into the hospital so yeah it
takes a little while to absorb the whole
cancer patient thing doesn't really seem
like that's you at first but they do
once you're in there hit you with a lot
of signage at every opportunity to drive
home the situation also I feel like most
Hospital waiting rooms don't have this
many tissues like I feel bad for not
crying when I'm in here John today was
my very first radiation therapy
appointment which was weird and I want
to tell you about it so just a quick
recap I started the solving with
chemotherapy which killed so much of my
cancer that they can no longer find it
inside of me which is great but they do
think that it is likely that I still
have what they call microscopic disease
and it's probably centered in the area
of my body where my lymph nodes were
previously very swollen we have a high
resolution picture of that from when I
was for first diagnosed and so the idea
is to aim a beam of radiation at just
that area of my body where my lymph
nodes used to be swollen and thus to
just like explode whatever cancer cells
are still in there because cancer cells
are more susceptible to radiation than
regular cells now that doesn't mean that
this isn't also going to screw up some
of irregular cells it will just hurt the
cancer cells worse now I gotta say
radiation therapy is a little weird the
whole idea is that you're going to go
lay down in front of a particle
accelerator that's going to shoot high
energy photons into you at like a rate
that is somewhat comparable to what
people who worked on the fukushimu plant
after it melted down received it's
enough radiation that if you got it to
your whole body and all at once rather
than like spread out over several weeks
the way that they do it you would die
like you would die immediately and
terribly but they don't give it to you
all at once and they don't give it to
your whole body so you don't die which
is awesome as I always say not dying
from radiation poisoning is amazing so
yeah it seems like it'd be a pretty
intense experience but it's not it's
entirely silent and you feel nothing you
lay there for eight minutes and then you
go get McDonald's now the thing itself
is very cool it moves around and it
shoots from several different angles and
the idea is that it can hit the diseased
area like from this angle and then from
this angle and then from this angle and
that means that the place where all
those things are intersecting is getting
a super high dose like the cross gets
the high dose but the finger Parts get
like half Doses and you do that five
times and then where all the beams are
meeting get five times the dose and all
the other places get like one-fifth the
dose of the middle but also in order to
shape the beam so that's the exact size
of like where my lymph node inflammation
used to be there's this adaptive shutter
thing that like changes shape and it
like almost looks alive it's very cool
to see in person but unlike the
animation I just showed you the
radiation is invisible so it doesn't
look or feel like anything it's super
bizarre because you know it's this big
thing but I like chemotherapy which like
has a feeling this is like nothing which
doesn't mean that it's not like a big
deal and it's not dangerous it turns out
I'm a good candidate for radiation
therapy one because where my cancer was
means they can hit it with a bunch of
beams without hitting my heart they're
gonna hit like a little bit of my lung
but not with a lot of dose and so that's
not as much of a concern and also it's
because I'm kind of old like if I was
seven years old I'd have 80 years to
potentially get a secondary cancer from
my radiation therapy but I'm 43 so I
only got like half that time to develop
a secondary cancer which means my
chances of developing a secondary cancer
are lower like this is the math they
have to do because treating cancer isn't
really about getting the chances of cure
as high as possible it's getting the
chances of cure as high as possible
while also getting the chances of severe
side effects from the treatment as low
as possible and those side effects are
really significant they could be like
heart failure like straight heart
failure where you have to either get a
heart transplant or die they can be
secondary cancers that are more
dangerous than the one that I currently
have you can get a pulmonary embolism
you can get a stroke these aren't side
effects that are annoying there are side
effects that can kill you so cancer
treatment like a lot of things is not so
much about decisions as it is about
trade-offs now do I love the fact that
we could be doing more to prevent
relapse but we aren't because there's
all these other things to consider no
but like that's the situation we are in
so I laid there for eight minutes and
then I went and got McDonald's and then
I was on the wrong side of town so I
doordashed Boba to my house and then
judging from the receipt that I received
I got Dakota Sushi and I assume that
Dakota got my Boba so Dakota I hope that
you enjoy my Boba because I am enjoying
your sushi because look you got to take
what life gives you and life gave me
cancer and decoded Sushi John I'll see
you on Tuesday